let's get the thoughts of our paper
reviewers Liam Thorpe and Claire
Ellicott who as you can see are in the
screen behind me Liam Claire thank you
so much for your patience this evening
it's uh got quite busy suddenly and
let's just pick up Claire if we can on
where we find ourselves right now with
um a man who was president wants to be
president again but now faces hugely
serious charges in a Manhattan Court
it's an absolutely extraordinary story
it's broken by the New York Times just a
few minutes ago and um this would be an
incredible thing you know he is an
former U.S president he'd be the first
in history and to be convicted of
something like this if the you know the
indictment goes ahead
um and so it's you know he's a president
whose entire time in office was dodged
by controversy and um he's standing
again next time in the next elections
next year uh this is going to hang over
him it's clear that you know we'll find
out in the coming days what exactly he's
indicted of because this is all this is
all seal is sealed indictment we don't
know the exact details yet but it
involves a tordury sort of
um accusations about the porn star
Stormy Daniels and whether or not she
was paid hush money and what happened as
a result of that and you know this is a
former president of the United States
the prospect of him being going in with
the Secret Service protection he has to
be you know fingerprinted and
photographed mugshot taken I mean it's
absolutely extraordinary he'll he'll
appear in front of a judge and as we've
heard from your correspondents you know
he's doing well in the Republican run-up
he is um he's doing well in the polls
and his closest competitor the Florida
governor Ron DeSantis is training behind
him so you have to think that you know
this would this wouldn't upset Trump's
campaign for next year not least because
it will no doubt drag on and he's facing
other investigations as well I think
there are three other investigations
which are deemed to be more serious than
this one so he's in a lot of trouble
um but as usual he's painting this as a
political Witch Hunt he's saying you
know that the the people who oppose his
views are coming after him his son's
statement so that you know speaks to
that he's clearly you know rattled by
this um he's said to be in his
Mar-A-Lago mansion in Florida or
processing all of this at the moment and
but the prospect of him you know being
hauled into a New York courtroom in the
coming days it's absolutely
extraordinary would be a real moment in
American history yeah and another one
Claire I mean processing probably one
thing raging I think as well and Liam
it's just it's just remarkable isn't it
that you know of all the things that
we've seen happen with Donald Trump you
know from the the allegation that
included with Russia was but uh
indicting a riot on Capitol Hill and now
the fact that he could well be facing um
well he's going to face a judge could
well face trial but still as Claire was
laying out is ahead in the polls and
there is not it's not clear whether or
not to still be able to run or if you
get selected will be able to be
president
well I mean what games your
correspondent just said about from
potentially you know journalists in
America now are trying to write pieces
about whether Trump could be a serving
president from behind bars it just is
just the most extraordinary thing I
can't quite believe I'm I'm saying that
on television it's an incredible story
and I think it really speaks to these
these febrile times that we're in there
would have been a time and you know if
you look at Richard Nixon or other
people wear a scandal like this a news
like this would just be the end of a
political career but actually this will
ignite Trump's base that's the quite
scary thing you just mentioned what
happened on on January 6th we saw how
scary things can get when he fires up
that base when he claims conspiracy when
he claims Witch Hunt and this is that's
you know in some ways this is even more
explosive than that when those pictures
of him and you know hearing your last
guests say I think we all guess that
it's he's going to go for a very public
route on this who's going to fire it up
I I don't know if you guys have been
paying attention to what's been going on
in Park City Utah clay you look like you
may have been I'm not sure
but it looks like Gwyneth Paltrow uh
according to the jury there uh did not
do it and now Terry Sansa knows her a
dollar
Matt
um so Gwyneth Paltrow the actress she
seemed to have won this case which I
think Terry Sanderson brought it so it's
interesting that she seemed to have won
everything
um they were counter-suing each other
and she demanded a dollar he was suing
for three hundred thousand dollars but I
believe he also has to pay her legal
fees now which I'd imagine is is a quite
substantial amount of money but the
actress has come in every day and sat
through this trial and looking you know
pristine and she gave a little smile
there as the verdict was was read out
but you know she was obviously accused
of harming this man and causing you know
huge injuries to him breaking his ribs
and you know other injuries and I think
she was he suggested she was distracted
by her children being on the slopes at
the ski slopes at the time are all this
happened and um she obviously took real
umbrage with this so it's quite an
extraordinary case and you know the fact
that she's been there the entire time
and you know she's you know this really
famous actress it's just it's quite it's
strawberry and you know she's one house
so yeah I guess um a good day for her
yeah I guess it is a good day for her
and as you're right uh Claire I think
Terry Samson will have to pay her
illegal fees which could be could be
quite substantial but I guess Liam the
thing about this you know it's another
trial in America with famous people and
it just the fact that we get to sort of
see them having to go through this is is
captivating in and of itself even though
you know this one didn't have sort of a
lot of the Peril that some of the recent
trials that we've watched had in them or
some of the the drama but still it was a
case of who did this who was the
downhill skier who was the uphill skier
some of the detail was quite
entertaining at times
yeah as a journalist who's who's sat in
court in this uncovered stories in this
uh country and obviously we're not
allowed cameras in and you have to kind
of use your skills to to bring to life
the the human drama which we just sat
and watched there you know it's
extraordinary to watch it happening live
and sometimes you forget that in America
that that is not
um a comprehensive win for Gwyneth
Paltrow and I haven't been following it
really closely but I know that obviously
the case was brought against her Terry
Sanderson is is claiming was claiming
that he's been badly injured and he's
had a really bad repercussions from this
so it's a really a really sort of huge
defeat for him not only did they find
that she wasn't at fault they found that
he was at fault and he's you know she's
not demanding a lot of money because
she's a multi-millionaire but it's this
nominal fee to kind of I guess to kind
of say look you I've had to sit through
this she is a human being she might be
super famous and very rich but it can't
have been nice as as Claire said she's
gone there every day and it's probably
pretty traumatic so you'll be feeling
pretty good right now but yeah just as
you say an extraordinary spectacle to
watch play out I'm wondering what new
users coming next from America tonight
I'm sorry about this guys it has been
quite the evening for American News
hasn't it and can I just I mean it's on
that thing the courtroom drama I mean
it's always I don't know if this tells
you too much about me but it's always my
best bit in some of these films so we
get to the courtroom drama moment
because it becomes really real doesn't
it then you know you've got your under
oath you can't lie you gotta you gotta
tell the truth and that's when you
really reveal Parts about people and
that's what was so fascinating in this
case I don't know if you saw Terry
Sanderson pulled back to the stand and
was sort of torn apart for some posts on
his social media after the accident
yeah and um you know every day she's
she's been there and you know dressed up
and being dragged into the courtroom
every day this doesn't happen in the UK
as Liam says we sit there and we take
shorthand notes and there have been a
think a few Trials of if you know
televising court trials but in the UK
but that's not happened yet and um you
know in the U.S you do get to sit
through every single moment of it and
you get to see a you know famous
Hollywood actress the important to stand
and having to give evidence it's
unremarkable really and um it has been a
fascinating case to follow I think
Taylor Swift has come out
um you know there have been various
other mentions of famous people and um
it just shows you I guess sometimes
these extraordinary people do actually
have you know quite run-of-the-mill
things happen to them and we get to we
get to watch it all play out and so you
know Showbiz I guess yeah it is very
true because all right guys thank you
very much for that I mean to shut up
gear change now if you don't mind we're
going to move on to look at some of our
domestic newspapers uh now uh Jane and
Ellen we're going to start with you uh
we're going to start with your newspaper
and the front page that we've got there
I mean covering court cases of course
you would have been in court uh for the
past few covering this and there is the
front page of of the echo uh for
tomorrow morning
um following the conviction of Thomas
Cashman
yeah um so it wasn't actually myself in
court a crime reports when our court
reports we've spent the last sort of
three and a half weeks covering this
incredibly distressing complicated
delicate difficult trial and you know
I'd like to pay tribute to them for
their extraordinary coverage of this um
it's vital you know we don't have
cameras in the court like in America
it's vital the role of reporter in this
country that they that justices seem to
be done through them and it's really
challenging cases you can imagine both
legally and emotionally you know
Liverpool is in mourning for Olivia
Pratt Corbell we have been since uh she
was tragically taken in the most
horrific circumstances and while of
course this today's result will not
bring her back or we can all hope is
that it brings a semblance of peace to
her amazing courageous uh dignified
family we saw Cheryl Corbell
um outside the courtroom celebrating
with with Olivia's um toy in a really
emotional scene and I just wanted to say
on our front page today our editorial
team made a decision that we wanted
Olivia to be on our front page not
Thomas Cashman not a scowling
um uh
evil Thug who who was so brazenly shot
into a domestic house we wanted to
celebrate her amazing life and her mum
talks about her being you know nosy
cheeky funny her Shadow this wonderful
little girl who we will not be able to
see
um grow up because of that man and
Justice was served today and we're all
very relieved yeah her mum called her
the baby didn't she it's just a really
sort of touching way of describing her a
little girl
um in the tragic circumstances in which
she died let's move on to the front page
of the mail and uh here here on on um
what you said uh Liam about court
reporters being in in the room to to
make sure that these things are covered
and on the front page of the mail uh
Claire here we've you know we've got the
sort of stuff
juxtaposition of lovely Olivia and then
the Man convicted of the killing and uh
and the really shocking picture on the
front page of the paper I mean there's
nothing else to say about that is there
he's a drug dealer this Thomas Cashman
man and he's um you know he's he's been
found guilty now he's going to be I
think sentenced next week it's a
horrific trial and you know it's just
contrasting you know this this cute
little girl is totally innocent like you
know playing in our house I think she's
just about to go to bed and um this man
comes running in the house he's trying
to execute someone else and she gets
caught in the crossfire it sadly reminds
me of a of another case Rhys Jones it
was a huge huge case in Liverpool back
in the day he was a young boy he was 11
years old he got caught in the crossfire
in another similar circumstance and
actually I was on the Liverpool Echo at
the time and
um when his murder was being tried in
and caught and you know it's just it's a
repeated story you know you hear all
these stories about drug dealers about
and I think there's some of the other
front pages have mentioned that the
police officer leading the investigation
into Olivia's murder
um he actually said that anybody who
uses recreational drugs in the UK is to
blame for this pace because the you know
the the Gangland murders you know the
history of drugs county lines this had a
real effect on this country and you've
really seen that the Prime Minister has
been announcing a Crackdown on
anti-social behavior in recent weeks
because it does blight communities and
it leads to sad sad cases like this and
Liverpool is a community that's going
through another case like this again and
it shouldn't be happening desperately
unfair and something does really need to
be done about about the drugs that are
blight in the whole of the UK yeah
Claire I really do appreciate that and
I'm really glad that we managed to get
to that front page guys we've got to
leave it there because we've got more
U.S news coming but appreciate your time
really delighted we got to see those
front pages uh Liam Thorp and clerical
thank you so much for your time this
evening